the square root of 3 is an irrational
number so how do we plot this on a
number line let's see in a previous
video we had seen how to plot square
root of 2.
here we shall take length abs square
root of 2 and from 8 we draw a
perpendicular bc of 1 unit we will
obtain the length of ac square root of
three now this concept can be applied on
the number line here is a number line
first we shall draw square root of two
posts that a perpendicular of one unit
this length obtained the square root of
three and with the help of a compass we
shall project the same length on the
number line
and we obtain length od that is square
root of 3. similarly can you tell me how
to plot square root of phi on the number
line share your answer in the comments
section